bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
domaine de l'éco sur france24
l'allemagne dit oui au programme grec le
bundestag vote la prolongation de quatre
mois du plan d'aidé financière à athènes
alexis tsipras ce premier ministre grec
at-il capituler sous la pression de ses
partenaires que contient le compromis
actuel
la réforme du dialogue social dans les
entreprises est de retour en france
après l'échec des négociations manuel
valls a convoqué syndicats et patronat
et souhaite une réforme ambitieuse alors
le sera-t-elle le premier ministre en at
il les moyens en face wikileaks suite
les patrons de hsbc renouvellent leurs
excuses sans convaincre les
parlementaires britanniques sur les
pratiques de fraude fiscale de leurs
filiales suisses comment expliquer
l'ampleur du phénomène où en est on de
la levée du secret bancaire
et on en parle avec mes invités avec moi
sur ce plateau robert rochefort bonjour
député européen et vice-président du
modem céline antonin bonjour vous êtes
économiste en chef chez eux et jean marc
daniel bonjour jean marc economista le
s&p europe alors feu vert du bundestag
et bien oui on l'attendait c'est
l'assemblée nationale allemande feu vert
à la prolongation de quatre mois du plan
d' aide financière à athènes alexis
tsipras ce premier ministre grec at il
capitule et finalement sous la pression
de ses partenaires que contient le
compromis actuel quelques réactions et
on en débat tout de suite
ces réformes sont positives nous aurons
un accord avec la grèce
depuis ce matin la consommation a repris
comme avant
je crois que l'espoir est venu
moi je crois que rien n'a changé depuis
hier nous donne les os à ronger la
syriza va nous dire nous avons gagné la
bataille mais l'opposition mais ils
n'ont rien fait c'est toujours la même
chose ya pa très
motivés j'espère qu'à la fin de cette
période de quatre mois
conservant une position de négociation
meilleur aujourd'hui et je crois que
c'est qu'un autre question primordiale
de l'europe la question de la continuité
ou non des politiques d'austérité
est ce qu'il nie il ne s'agit pas
d'accorder de nouveaux milliards à la
grèce est non nous ne voulons pas
changer le programme est plutôt
accorder davantage de temps pour
souhaite pour que le programme
atteigne son but
vous êtes politique du plateau alors il
a capitulé avec cette phrase devant ses
partenaires moi je pense que c'est pas
intéressant de le dire comme ça
effectivement on est très très loin du
programme électoral ce qui est important
c'est qu'ils aient eu un accord ce qui
est important c'est de gagner du temps
c'est le gall c'est doux c'est de gagner
du temps finalement vous savez quelle
est la bonne nouvelle dans cette affaire
que bundestag dit oui bien sûr mais la
bonne nouvelle plus globalement c'est
que le gouvernement grec il a une petite
chance qui est peut-être de faire mieux
que son prédécesseur sur des questions
fondamentales que sont la réforme de
l'état en grèce le fait de faire rentrer
les impôts le fait effectivement d'avoir
des des armateurs et une église qui
paient correctement les impôts le fait
qu'on ait un cadastre alors pour
l'instant aucun de ses prédécesseurs
voit l'arrivée et ont fait faire une
véritable enfant voyez ça c'est une
réforme qui est une réforme qui peut
très bien aller avec une idée de gauche
pour faire simple maintenant c'est
compliqué parce qu'il faut mettre les
gens au travail c'est pas qu'une
question de nombre d'effectifs de
fonctionnaires ici ou là donc je pense
qu'il faut espérer que le gouvernement
grec qui arrivera en contrepartie qu'est
ce qu'ils ont gagné ils ont gagné un peu
plus de flexibilité la possibilité
peut-être de faire des trocs entre tel
ou tel type 2 mesures d'économies
qu'avant on leur avait imposé de force
par la troïka avec d'ailleurs un
gouvernement grec précédent qui
réagissait pas qui disait wiki qui
prenait ce qu'on lui dicte est là un
gouvernement qui négociera plus bon et
un petit peu plus de respiration c'est
pas miraculeux mais mais j'espère qu'en
tout cas le peuple grec va ne va pas
lâcher aujourd'hui le gouvernement tel
qu'il est vous savez il faut tenir
compte de la ville à vis des électeurs
donc voilà et puis dans les quatre mois
qui viennent espérons effectivement
qu'on arrivera à négocier un troisième
plan je crois que il faut que la grèce
reste dans la zone euro il faut que la
grèce restant en lice à rester la grèce
la grèce a fait des efforts
considérables il faut pas oublier quand
même au cours des années passées il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été
faits par le peuple les antennistes
lorsqu'on regarde le compromis on se
demande alors en dehors du fait qu
effectivement avec ses 6 presse doit
mettre en place cette réforme fiscale ce
qui n'a pas été fait tout le reste enfin
ce sont ces que c'est l'austérité comme
avant alors c'est l'austérité comme
avant peut-être modulo quand même le
fait qu'ils puissent mettre en place son
programme d'urgence donc qu'il avait
promis à la population et qui était un
petit peu son va-tout aussi donc c'est à
dire mettre en place des bons
alimentaires l'axé et laisse alors c'est
assez flou là dessus alors c'est un pas
très bien je suis d'accord que c'est
assez flou mais enfin il a quand même
obtenu également 7,7 compensation là et
je crois que sa vraie monnaies change
c'était vraiment ça c'était la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale parce que c'est
quand même ça qui à mon avis a réussi à
convaincre les la commission par les
institutions européennes qu'ils allaient
lutter contre la fraude jusqu'à la sepra
ils allaient lutter alors ils parlent
d'un chiffre de 2 7 milliards d'euros
fin qui seraient rapportés par par la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale ce qui
est quand même énorme donc et le fait de
faire rentrer des recettes ça a
convaincu la commission parce que l'idée
c'était de pouvoir financer son plan
après la question est de savoir est-ce
qu'il va vraiment arriver à le faire
alors il semble que y est sans doute
moins de lien aussi avec le disons
qu'avec les anciens avec les anciens ce
qui permettrait de faire entrer les
roses est en même temps on a toujours eu
des chiffres qui annoncé une lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale qui était très
important après on n'a pas forcément eu
des résultats à la hauteur donc il faut
voir ce qui va être vraiment réaliser
mais je crois que c'était vraiment ça et
de toute façon pour moi ce qui s'est
joué c'était pas un dialogue de sourds
ma faim on savait plus ou moins ce qui
allait en sortir de ce compromis on
savait que la zone euro n'avait quand
même pas intérêt à laisser tomber la
grèce parce que ça aurait créé un
précédent et ça on savait très bien que
de toute façon on ne voulait pas ouvrir
la boîte de pandore et faire en sorte
qu' il ya une déstabilisation parce que
le risque c'était que d'autres pays
après en prennent de la graine donc pour
moi c'était assez évident ce qui allait
jouer et le fait que si prasad et de
toute façon faire des concessions
s'était pas non plus pour moi enfin
quelque chose de très exceptionnel donc
je crois que finalement il fallait le
faire alors jean marc dagher choses
entre ces promesses effectivement et ce
qui s'est passé lundi dernier il ya tout
de même un fossé rue je crois qu'il a
capitulé capituler en rase campagne je
pense qu'il a capitulé pour deux raisons
la première raison c'est que son
programme était un programme qui était à
la fois un programme de renégociation de
la dette or le problème de la dette est
plutôt derrière la grèce encore une fois
quand on regarde les chiffres mais on va
revenir à ça quand on regarde les
chiffres la charge d'intérêts de la
grèce ces 9 milliards on brut est
contenue d'un certain relâchement qui
sont encore dans le palais de l'elysée
des décisions européennes c'est plutôt 6
milliards apportés à 320 milliards de
dettes ça fait un taux d'intérêt
apparent un taux d'intérêt sur la dette
qui est à 3% dont qui est inférieur à
celui de l'italie par exemple donc un
taux d'intérêt oui oui oui
le deuxième élément de programmes
c'était une relance redistributive à
l'ancienne comme on faisait dans les
pays sociaux démocrates et travaillistes
en saas est exclu aujourd'hui tout ça ça
a été balayée et donc il y là il a
abandonné son programme ne serait ce que
parce que sont prononcés comme avant
alors que le fmi reconnaît même joue
aussi dans le fmi finalement
l'ajustement s'est fait au prix d'une
compression des dépenses qui a touché
les plus vulnérables plutôt que des
réformes structurelles alors
le deuxième et les leurres ça ne
fonctionne pas non le deuxième élément
c'est quand même que il a conservé le
symbole un certain nombre de symboles il
gère ça très bien donc la référence le
nom pisco face au nein allemand il ya le
haut qui est une référence dans
l'histoire grecque au refus de
l'invasion italienne dans les années 40
il est allé voir theodorakis
donc il sauve la face sur la place mais
plus ou moins bien d'ailleurs parce que
dans la sphère des 500 femmes de ménage
du ministère des finances qui devaient
être réembauchés sur-le-champ elles sont
toujours en attente d'un message le bon
donc il sauve l'alsace à réembaucher il
est toujours dans la logique de
finalement le véritable déficit c'est un
déficit de dignité et je pense que ça il
le joue assez bien mais sur le plan
économique il a capitulé et on commence
à voir des tensions dans sa majorité je
pense que la leçon qu'il faut en tirer
par delà ce que dit le fmi parce que
aussi dans les analyses du fmi ce que
les gens ne voient pas c'est qu'il ya
toute une partie l'économie grecque qui
s'est mise au noir donc on retrouve le
problème de la fraude fiscale parce qu
on parle d armateurs entretenu avec très
grosses économies parallèles et il ya
une économie parallèle la quantité de
billets en circulation en grèce d'après
les dernières statistiques de la banque
centrale ces 30 milliards d'euros prouve
bien l'échec de ses politiques oui
absolument remarquable seulement d'une
certaine façon elles sont illégitimes
sur le plan je suis d'accord elles sont
illégitimes sur le plan politique et sur
tous les outils qui ont été mises en
place ne sont pas efficaces parce
qu'effectivement la population trouve le
moyen d'échapper donc il faut réfléchir
à la structure de la fiscaux qui font
réfléchir alors justement va réfléchir
sur problématique de la dette sinon
autant je voudrais vous faire réagir ce
qu'a dit louis schweitzer c'était
l'ancien patron de renault il est
aujourd'hui commissaire général à
l'investissement et vous réagirez à ce
qu'il a dit justement sur la dette
grecque les grecs ont proposé autre
chose ils ont proposé de rendre une
partie de la dette perpétuelle de revoir
les taux d'intérêt effacez la dette et
ça vous pensez que ce serait une bonne
idée
je suis favorable
on sait quand une entreprise a des
difficultés qu'est ce que font les
créanciers ils se réunissent et il voit
à quelle condition l'entreprise sur l'ip
absolument il y en a fait toujours mieux
que de laisser crever ne pas laisser ne
pas laisser crever les grecs c'est ce
qu'a dit oui donc renégocier la dette
dont j'avais vu quand même ce qui s'est
passé aussi ces deux choses la première
c'est que d'un ancien patron de rue et
même stade et la première c'est que les
grecs se sont rendu compte qu'ils
n'avaient pas délier c'est à dire que en
réalité plus les autres pays avait été
touché par des efforts au cours des
années passent et plus il disait il faut
que la grèce paye parce que le vrai
problème il est là le problème il est
pas le cas grec par lui-même il et quels
risques de contagion par rapport au
reste des pays à risque de contagion la
11 et donc si on reprend la question de
schweitzer évidemment tout le monde
c'est que de toute façon il y avait des
plans de restructuration mais qui serait
venu en leur temps on ne peut pas les
faire à chaud c'est ça peut-être que je
peux dire n'a pas compris c'est qu'on
peut le faire pour une entreprise
pourrait le faire aussi passer une
entreprise c'est une entreprise on met
un instant t là on est sur un contexte
politique européen dans lequel ça ne
pouvait pas se faire à chaud et donc ils
sont rendu compte qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
été seuls je rajoute à ça moi je suis un
peu triste quand même par le fait qu'on
a le sentiment que c'était uniquement
l'allemagne qui était en face comme si
la question il faudra avoir de force
quand c'est être chef bleu et vert ou
fake c'est bien ce que je vous dis mais
je suis un peu triste j'aurais aimé si
vous voulez que y ait quelque chose de
beaucoup plus collégiale l'europe de
demain sur le plan économique et
politique ne peut pas être uniquement
l'allemagne qui impose et puis de temps
en temps des mauvais élèves qui
ponctuellement lèvent le doigt et puis
qui se font punir par un petit poucet
iena garage et c'est sur cette caisse
michel juste pour revenir sur cette
question de la dette alors je pense que
bon effectivement la question de la
renégociation de la dette se pose alors
déjà elle s'est posée en 2012 puisque
les créanciers privés avec c'est
accepter une première donc avec cette
ténébreuse prêté à 100 milliards voilà
100 milliards d'euros c'est bon pour les
créanciers du public la question peut
également se poser alors sachant qu'ils
auraient de toute façon des créanciers
privés mon prioritaire je pense aux
familles je m'en sors à la bce également
mais il faut quand même penser aussi que
les pays européens ont prêté à la grèce
un montant important bond alors
l'équivalent en disant de 240 milliards
mais surtout lors de prêts bilatéraux la
france par exemple en fait il ya 40
milliards qui ont été à peu près prêter
à la grèce ça voudrait dire renoncer
pour le contribuable enfin en fait pour
le contribuable français ça serait
effectivement renoncé elle coûterait
combien j'ai pas fait les calculs on
parle de 6 ans 6 600 euros par part
ménages ont fait en tout cas si d'autres
pays s'en inspira prêt pour faire la
même chose quand je veux dire ça a quand
même des répercussions non négligeables
donc je pense que ça doit venir dans un
deuxième temps on doit effectivement
réfléchir la grèce ne pourra pas
rembourser les 175 % d'endettement c'est
évident mais ça doit venir dans un
deuxième temps ça doit se faire de façon
concertée est effectivement eu à mon
avis ça doit surtout c'est aller dans la
durée enfin je veux dire on va voir
comment ça va se faire après il faut
laisser dans ce cas là sion il ya des
choses qui peuvent jouer dans la durée
mais de décréter brutalement un haircut
comme on l'a fait sur la dette je pense
que ça serait un peu irresponsable je
changerais rien apporté deux sûrement
saisir la première chose c'est qu'une
dette publique serait pour moi ça se
rembourse pas ses dettes
monsieur choix de servir on devrait
faire une barrette perpétuelle mais les
perpétuelles la dette à chaque fois on
la renouvelle on l'a pour jouer de la
dette quand même qu'ils peuvent parler
aux et gia jamais le remboursement il
restait simplement les charges d'intérêt
et pourra revenir aux charges d'intérêts
le charges d'intérêts maintenant de la
dette grecque est une les plus faibles
d'europe on a tellement à baisser les
taux d'intérêts tellement
artificiellement avec les charges
d'intérêts quand même énorme car elle
est de 6 milliards d'euros encore une
fois si on applique le dernier plan les
dernières décisions prises par le
gouvernement précédent sur un but chez
sur une dette créée 320 milliards et sur
un budget fait 80 milliards d'euros la
charge de la dette c'est 6 me en tout
cas on a d'ici au mois de juin puisque
finalement bien le besoin de financement
mais la charge de la dette la chair la
chambre voilà mais la dette entière
c'est 75% du pib' il faut le rappeler
gravelines cas jusqu'à fin juin pour
l'ensemble des négociations et bientôt
on en reparlera la réforme du dialogue
social dans les entreprises est de
retour en france après l'échec des
négociations manuel valls a convoqué
syndicats et patronat le premier
ministre souhaite une réforme ambitieuse
at il dit alors le sera t-elle en at il
les moyens quelques actions et on en
débat ensuite
il y aura pas a priori de discussion sur
réforme énième du marché du travail il y
aura une évaluation sauf un truc un peu
trouble c'est on va travailler sur
comment favoriser l'embauché dans les
tpe j'ai demandé au premier ministre si
vous allez nous refaire un coût de ces
pays n'ont visiblement je sais pas ce
qui va faire je salue la volonté du
premier ministre de réformer la france
et doit faire de réformes et le dialogue
social par contre en effet nous serons
très vigilants parce que d'abord il ya
urgence à réformer ce dialogue social le
dialogue social nous y croyons bien
évidemment au medef c'est extrêmement
important pour la compétitivité du pays
aujourd'hui il faut le réformer dans un
sens de simplification déficiences et je
dirais de confiance pas vu le sourire
qu'à monsieur gattaz du est satisfait
nous pas du tout le gouvernement a
proposé en tout cas dans les grandes
lignes quelque chose qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu'avait proposé le medef
lors de la précédente négociation donc
on ne peut pas être satisfait on le voit
bien ben arfa le dialogue se sent-il pas
en panne en france si bien sûr que si il
est en panne vous savez on j'ai peur
qu'on nous joue la loi maquereau en bis
avec le projet rebsamen c'est à dire
qu'on va faire une petite réforme et on
va avoir le sentiment qu'on est en train
de faire quelque chose qui va mettre
peut-être dans la rue je n'en sais rien
enfin tous les protagonistes dans un
psychodrame absolue quelle est la
réalité la réalité c'est que le l'accord
qui n'a pas eu lieu entre les
partenaires sociaux étaient déjà déploré
j'aurais dû leur mettre d'amis j'aurais
préféré qu'il ya un accord entrepreneurs
sont partenaires sociaux mais même si
cet accord avait eu lieu on aurait été
très en deçà de ce qu'il faut faire quel
est le problème aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que les partenaires sociaux
regarde les sujets en interne c'est à
dire les gens qui sont dans l'entreprise
qui sont protégés comme on le disait il
ya quelques temps la verite le véritable
enjeu aujourd'hui c'est l'intérêt
général sert comment faire en sorte que
ce dialogue social favorise la création
d'emplois renouvelle les embauches et là
je crois qu'on est pas idéal social
moderne alors bon alors bon si on peu un
tout petit peu parce que c'est ça
l'enjeu avec cette loi l'iss est un tout
petit peu ce qu'on appelle les effets de
seuil et en particulier les fans ne l'a
plus d effet décider si précis parce que
la représentation unique du personnel on
va aller jusqu'à 300 dans les
entreprises donc peut-être on va un tout
petit peu un tout petit peu des places
l'effet de seuil oui mais mais mais
c'est déjà mieux de l'avoir à 300 que de
l'avoir à 50 mais mais désormais si vous
voulez dire c'est que c'est pas
suffisant oui je suis évidemment
d'accord mais je vous dis simplement
voilà et le problème c'est que entre la
loi macro et la future loi romaine ce
sera pour laquelle auront été les deux
piliers des réformes économiques et
sociales du quinquennat hollande et
c'est dramatique parce que en tout cas
je crois qu'il ya aucun économiste
sérieux qui n'est donc premier des cas
de figure ni dans le second est capable
de dire ça ça va nous donner x % de
croissance en plus dans la croissance
économique en général et dans la
croissance de l'emploi en plus c'est une
entonna en panne ce dialogue social avec
clairement bon plus fin pour moi c'est
quand même
un camouflet pour françois hollande qui
avait quand même promis de effectivement
de dax et enfin je veux dire son
quinquennat de le placer sous le signe
du dialogue social et on voit bien que
ça ne marche pas donc on arrive vraiment
un
un échec alors que cette réforme soit
validée essentielle tant tissandier de
l'emploi pour essentiel pour créer de
l'emploi je ne sais pas alors sur les
effets de seuil c'est très partagés vous
avez certains économistes qui vous
disent que ça pourrait effectivement
supprimer les effets de seuil pourrait
vraiment créer de l'emploi dans le
rapport cahuc rammaert ce qu'ils disent
est effectivement qu'il y avait un petit
effet des effets de seuil d'autres qui
vous dit que ça ne joue pas beaucoup ça
joue marginalement je pense
qu'effectivement enfin mois pour avoir
un petit peu travaillé sur le sujet on
voyait clairement par exemple qu'à 1 49
salariés on avait un vrai effet de seuil
et que les entreprises n'embauchent pas
puisque justement dont elle avait grossi
celle de 1,6 et pas où on est vraiment
d'avoir enfin énormément de profits pour
pouvoir le faire donc je pense qu'il ya
effectivement la question des effets de
seuil qu'on ne règle pas avec cette
réforme donc ça c'est la première chose
et ensuite je pense que effectivement la
réforme est très en deçà de ce qu'on
attend par exemple au niveau des
réflexions qu'on pourrait mener à
l'heure actuelle je pense qu'il ya une
vraie réflexion à mener sur le contrat
de travail sur la distinction entre cdd
et cdi par exemple puisque on a un
emploi un marché de l'emploi qui est
très dual on réfléchit pas alors je dis
pas forcément aller vers l'emploi unique
vers le contrat unique mais je pense que
ça fait partie des pistes de réflexion
qui font en exclure aucune réfléchir
elle est totalement exclu aujourd'hui si
tout à fait mais je veux dire réfléchir
à la fécondation professionnelle à la
formation tout au long de la vie du
salarié ça ça me paraît plus important
de savoir ce qu'on fait des salariés à
l'heure où justement on augmente enfin
l'âge de départ à la retraite ça me
paraît plus important qu effectivement
mon quelques petites chamailleries
parfois pour savoir si untel doit rester
ou pas dans l'entreprise donc je pense
que il ya de vrais enjeux et
malheureusement on n'a pas su s'en
emparer 1 et pourquoi jean marc daniel
paré de toutes façons manuel valls n'a
pas les moyens de faire passer une telle
un tel projet à l'assemblée aujourd'hui
oui je pense qu'il ya tellement plus
important notre façon d'aborder le
problème la première façon on l'a vu
avec le lait le nouveau secrétaire
général la cgt il est dit si ça fait
plaisir monsieur gars tu as moi ça me
fait pas plaisir donc à partir de ce
moment là il n'y a pas que la cgt oui
mais pas à la cgt mais à partir de ce
moment là il est difficile de se mettre
d'accord il suffit que c'est ces jeux je
vous interdis d'être d'accord avec moi
d'en sortir cette physique oui donc on
est dans une logique et une logique
d'affrontement donc louis malys latif
sera différente mais finalement on n'est
pas loin je connais pas le deuxième
élément je pense qu'il ya quand même
dans les effets de seuil mais il ya pas
que des effets de seuil et tout
toilettage du code du travail qu'il faut
refaire qu'il faut faire parce que ce
code du travail il est issu
de toute une histoire il ya encore alors
tout le monde parle et dénoncé alors
qu'effectivement ça fait l'objet de
nombreux débats lors des des chambres
d'allaitement qui avait été prévu par la
loi thomas 1916 qui sont toujours le cas
du travail que font tous ces allègements
quand on l'avait dit à monsieur sapin
quand j'étais ministre du travail en lui
disant le code du travail est trop épais
il avait dit il ya qu'à réduire la
police de caractères du code comme ça il
sera moins épais donc je pense qu'il ya
aussi une sorte d'inertie politiques à
se dire la tâche est énorme c'est un
travail de romain de remettre l'ordre du
jour tout ce qu'il ya dans le code du
travail s'avère très difficile donc on
va prendre quelques petites mesures il
est clair que mission la formation
professionnelle par exemple qui coûte si
cher donc on n'en parle plus non plus
oui excusez moi aussi je le vois et
justement la loi sapin sur les idées
rien régler sur les effets de saint
yorre n'a quand même pas mal de travaux
effectivement c'est assez ambiguë les
résultats des travaux même seuil
économique entre guillemets qui est le
moment où une entreprise décide
d'embaucher un drh pour gérer le
personnel c'est à dire à partir de 70 75
personnes en général dans une entreprise
y un drh dans l'idée qu' un seuil
économique un seuil de gestion à 70 et
non pas à 50 est une idée assez simple
il faut être partagée car la troisième
réflexion que je ferai c'est que quand
même le monde évolue le salariat
d'aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec le
salariat du monde industriel des années
40-50 lala le le code du travail est
conçu sur une durée hebdomadaire du
travail
mode d'organisation du contrat de
travail qui lie au travail industriel en
a de plus amples de moins en moins de
salariés en fait de plus en plus d'auto
entrepreneur de relations ce sont des
relations marchandes en scène de
l'entrepreneuriat l'ordre règne de
l'entrepreneuriat et se caler dans une
organisation intellectuelle où on va
avoir une
vitam aeternam code du travail organisés
sur le travail industriel salariat du
xxème siècle me paraît dangereux il faut
aborder le problème véritablement en
changeant complètement de logiciels et
en se disant que le monde actuel c'est
une économie
où la durée du temps de travail perd son
sens et une économie est beaucoup plus
dé change beaucoup plus de contrat et
beaucoup moins d' organisation
hiérarchisée de rapports des règles tout
de même ab il faut des règles mais ces
règles peuvent pas être celle de lui
racheter une entreprise ou une règle
saint-georges parier que tout ce qui
permet à quelqu'un d'être actif soit
possible quel que soit le statut de
cette personne y compris un retraité qui
est retraité et qui veut avoir une
activité complémentaire donc c'est ça
qu'il faut faire et vous me permettrez
de rappeler sur le code du travail
puisque françois bayrou le rappelle à
chaque fois qu'il fait une émission de
télévision quand ils amènent le code du
travail français et le code du travail
suisse en montrant comment dire la
différence même si la suisse n'est pas
forcément comme un exemple qu'il faut
suivre mais il est incontestable que on
ne fait pas ce qu'il faut faire et ce
qui est préoccupant effectivement c'est
qu'en france finalement on ne le fait
pas quand on laisse les partenaires
sociaux s'organiser entre eux et on
risque de ne pas le faire non plus quand
on dit c'est la majorité le politique
qui aussi funky repas l'assemblée en mai
à ta swiss l'x parce qu'il nous reste
peu de temps les patrons s'étaient tout
de même aussi la grande l'actualité de
cette semaine puisque les patrons de
hsbc si la fameuse banque britannique
bien ont renouvelé leurs excuses alors
sans convaincre les parlementaires
britanniques sur les pratiques de fraude
fiscale de leurs filiales suisses et
pour cause stuart gulliver le patron des
chaînes bbc avait 7,6 millions de livres
sur son compte personnel au panama un
compte ouvert au sein de la filiale
suisse de hsbc sur lequel il transférait
des bonus quand il officiait à hong kong
c'est vrai que c'est un peu difficile à
soutenir céline antonin oui clairement
alors bon plus je trouve que c'est un
petit peu paradoxal parce que en octobre
2014 on a pris justement une décision
assez importante qui consistait enfin
les pays une 80 pays à peu près qui
après cette décision de favoriser
justement les échanges d'informations
alors ça doit prendre effet à partir de
2017 mais effectivement d'avoir cet
échange d'information un petit peu comme
la loi fatca qui se fait aux états unis
alors pas aussi de manière aussi
contraignante mais quand même avec donc
ces échanges d'information pour
connaître les clients des banques etc
est arrivé à faire du rap ont donc on
nier ou pas où on est et non justement
au nom des vingt sept sur sept doigts ça
doit se mettre en place progressivement
certains pays ont repoussé la date
jusqu'en 2018 alors l'autriche par
exemple en fait partie mais notamment
des pays comme le panama par exemple
font partie des pays qui ont accepté cet
échange d'informations et là on voit que
effectivement ben voilà c'est pas encore
du tout rentrer dans les moeurs etc et
déjà j'avais de grands doutes quant à
ted capacité à faire ça à partir de 2017
notamment parce qu'on résout pas
forcément les problèmes des sociétés
écrans en fait on déplore qu' à partir
d'un certain de 250000 euros en fait sur
un compte il va falloir connaître
effectivement la nationalité de la
personne connaître ses caractéristiques
qui a toujours un mois il ya un problème
y ait toujours un moyen de contourner
les sociétés écrans sont un moyen le
fait de diviser dans des comptes plus
petits sont aussi un moyen mais on
pouvait penser qu'on allait dans le sens
de l'amélioration et là ça nous montre
qu'il ya encore beaucoup de travail et
que c'est très compliqué hein on peut
mettre un tout petit bémol de petits ce
malgré tout parce que évidemment la
plupart des flammes des malgaches et pc
sont des turpitudes qui était quand même
il ya quelques années tout à fait et qui
décorent qui si on en croit les
dirigeants de shell décès sont quand
même de ne prendre en plus fort
aujourd'hui deuxième chose intéressante
je trouve c'est que ce soit les
britanniques ça se passe avec une banque
qui est à londres avec comment dire des
parlementaires briques elle passe devant
les parlementaires bien les dirigeants
je trouve ça très bien et le fait que ce
scandale sorte c'est aussi quelque chose
qui prouve que petit à petit comment
dire les choses se font autrement et je
pense que dans la communauté bancaire
malgré tout tout ceci ce sont des
signaux d'alert qu'ils vont faire avec
l'appui des politiques la force des
politiques et en particulier au
parlement européen parce qu'il faut
aussi une harmonisation européenne si
c'est sur ces sujets là j'espère que
nous allons aller dans la bonne
direction jean marc daniel oui match
dans cette affaire il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie d'abord de la part des
dirigeants de hsbc qui s'excuse
ses shows à l'américaine où ça le show à
l'américaine c'est presque mais aussi
beaucoup d'hypocrisie de la part des
gens qui ne veut pas véritablement faire
la différence entre la fraude fiscale et
l'optima l'optimisation parce qu'on voit
bien qu'ils ont prises ne joue pas
véritablement bancaire voilà que la
fraude fiscale soit condamné avec
extrême une extrême violence et une
extrême violence surtout ça normal mais
que des gens essaient d'échapper à
l'impôt est une espèce d'idée que
forcément dès que l'état vient vous
chercher dès que l'état vienne vous
réclamer quelque chose c'est légitime
c'est normal il a raison il ya aussi des
moments où les gens sont en droit de
s'interroger sur à quoi sert l'argent
qui est pris est ce qu'on peut pas
essayer dans le cadre de la loi
d'échapper à l'impôt et d'échapper à une
forme de violence que représente la
collecte de l'impôt donc il faut
évidemment que si on veut éviter de la
fraude l'optimisation fiscale et la
fuite devant l'impôt il faut
reconstruire une légitimation de la
dépense publique et je pense qu'un des
problèmes aussi c'est que de plus en
plus de gens ont la conviction qu'on
utilise mal les impôts je vois la
révolte du r est entre le rsi en ce
moment contre le régime social des
indépendants c'est aussi la conviction
chez des artisans chez des gens modestes
qui a difficilement leur vie que leur
est-il utilisation de l'argent qui sont
décents à mener a confié à ce système
n'est pas optimal donc perte de
légitimité des états effectivement ça
participe vous dites de cette
optimisation fiscale m'enfin bon c'est
vrai que les politiques voudraient aller
plus loin donc on peut mourir dans la
semaine on peut aussi rajouter
mcdonald's l'effet mcdonald's je pense
optimiser son visite été arrêté la
concurrence fiscale moi je de ce point
de vue humain ultralibéral peut-être
merci par les larmes
il faut non il faut harmoniser les
fiscalités en particulier sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés oui ça c'est un fait
mais il faut convaincre l'irlande il
faut d'abord qu'il faut convaincre
l'irlande est jeune on va créer un
journal mais elles viennent évidemment
si l'europe il est condamné ou ce
condamne elle même et autres pays
pas du tout c'est aussi un problème
merci à tous les trois en tout cas
d'avoir été désinvité merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis